rise and shine with those three little
words Kylie Jenner created the
Internet's new favorite meme rise and
shine the moment comes at the end of a
YouTube video by Jenner which shows the
makeup mogul singing to daughter stormy
after taking fans on a tour of her
cosmetics office and even ariana grande
could not resist rolling Kylie the
singer posted this Instagram story
tagging Kylie with the request can a
sample rise and shine
and get this Kylie responded saying yes
yes you can as long as I'm in the music
video is this the beginning of an ariana
Kylie collab it wouldn't be the first
time a member of the Kardashian famine
and Ariana Grande video Kris appeared in
Grande's Mean Girls inspired Thank You
next earlier this year in the meantime
Ari won't leave us hanging the Grammy
winner executive produced the soundtrack
for the upcoming Charlie's Angels movie
and collaborated with Miley Cyrus and
Lana Del Rey for don't call me angel
plus re is also teaming with Nicki Minaj
and normanni on another track he got up
with Nicki as she celebrated her prints
on collection for funding here's what
she told et about working with Ari how
cool to work with your sis I'm proud of
her because she executive produced that
album and I'm proud to be a part of
something you know that's her baby
yeah and it's always good working her
because we actually unlike with a lot of
artists we actually have a real
friendship outside of the real world the
people people don't realize that like we
actually took so we actually FaceTime
like we actually get on each other's
nerves stuff like that
you
[Applause]
[Music]